you know what I like watching people in
pain I don't know what it is
it never stops getting satisfying live
stream fails an excellent way to watch
people in pain you think I learned my
lesson Felix mmm-hmm I've suffered other
people less suffered let's see her
livestream fail the vast let's do more
reason this week hey look its fate but
first word from our sponsor should I do
this like david dobrik no word VPN
VPN gets 70% off a three-year I get it
it's boring to listen to this but it's
important it's about Internet safety you
want to feel safe while browsing
whatever you do online Nord VPN baby you
want ahead get it get this but I can't
afford 3.49 per month I think you can
afford it you get 70% off 70% off thanks
to me thanks for special offer
check out Nord VPN that calm slash
PewDiePie and enter the code PewDiePie I
know that's complicated I actually don't
think you have to enter the code if you
use the link not only can you browse the
internet safely err that's a word take
control of you Express today with the
VPN and right now you can get that's
that's Nord WebM that calms peopie to
take control of the Internet
again sorry I can't do it I don't know
how he does it you can decide wherever
you want to browse the internet from
wanna watch Mandalorian ok no much that
anymore but for example you can access
American shells you can ask this
Japanese shows you can go anywhere
online with this thing when I was in
Japan and I wanted to watch my normal
Netflix BAM I'm back you want to usually
soft furries what I'm saying
ok back to video now thanks nordley p.m.
first ones me in this video streamer
extra peopie calling him this simp
oh is that she knows what she's doing
her t matter of fact she does that she's
antagonizing this she's basically riling
up all the her simps with this hand
gesture I for the content that you're
watching because it's like people just
really have no really don't respect me
as a content creator the bad buddy if
you're if you're watching this and
you're like hey I want to stream you
know I'm gonna stream yes learn my
lesson don't defend a woman well of
course they don't
why the [ __ ] would they and then the
Sims come to add to the recipe she's an
attractive woman you know is the lack of
eye contact the lack of confidence the
posture that's all hit all three Synod
mommy I had all the eggs that I would be
so happy if you pulled out a monster any
during their that be
funny I mean that's funny III a mister
thought if he saw this he would just
like react like most people be like nope
keep it there at least like he has some
sort of self-awareness so I can't really
hate all night that's really funny
never defend the woman like what are you
them just kidding I'm joking by the way
it's a joke oh yes please
the content was removed by copper I
claim so I can't react to illinit II
getting bitten by her cat are you
serious
can I show it's still image and leaves
oh wait the music is copyrighted that's
why isn't it at this point okay just
imagine the most horrific singing voice
of all time basically funny look at the
freaking it gets a huge pile of meat
dude look at that
look at that that's so much I can't even
I'm nice as this is the conclusion of
that illinit e versus cat saga it ended
with a happy ending and the internet was
satisfied that's so funny
there's so much simpler lated kannan
lately okay boomergirl
that did a tick-tock and everyone just
lost their mind
[Music]
internet lost their absolute mind
she has burned the shirt I guess I would
birdie now isn't he out of the race she
was a catalyst for the simple war simp
queen basically that's her new name so
basically what happened was this video
got viral you probably know this I'm so
late on this the video went viral is
funny though
and then people found out she had a
boyfriend and she lost like 60 K and
then she made a response saying that
it's okay to simp
maybe I haven't done this in a while
maybe this year and we'll see what the
biggest ones are whatever you say boomer
got damaged so catchy though realist
post match interview ever that was a
tough loss how do you feel after that
yeah it was a good game we had a good
opponents our team wasn't really that
strong this year but we'll come back
this time expected reaction I don't like
the loudmouth
scream it calls boyfriend shy getting
all the girls I'm guaranteeing you
there's at least one girl looking at you
even though you're the shy guy oh yeah
he's really shy that's funny she didn't
get chat is that it can I say giga chad
that's the name of the meme but can't a
might like to say it deadmau5 opinion on
tipping and streamers
I'm so controlling Oh No it's so awkward
now yeah it's kind of weird as a
streamer criticising tipping although I
know it's more complicated than that at
least in America because sometimes you
don't get a salary you just get tips
which is kind of like that should not be
legal I don't even know if it should
maybe it's good for people I don't know
how it works over there so I shouldn't
criticize it so these are like up in
Miami
going out actually watch this girl do
stuff are you saying that they don't
have life damn simple was called out
early
I imagine guys like you could go outside
and be as cool as this guy Wow
we're all missing out that's funny
tongue movement oh that's hilarious
what a great clip semen right thing when
he drives what you call it's like semen
bro cement yeah oh good memes yes the
classic we don't know it's live yet
goddamn oh wow you know they got
instructions by someone be like alright
just stand here with the blank face and
be ready for the go so it's not really
their fault due to our casting team on
the commentators this
for you respect let's respect the right
there well done well done
took photos of girls in the video game
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's funny alright that's all for
livestream fails this time man it's fun
that was really fun so I should I can be
enjoyed and I'll see you guys tomorrow
Hado hey oh and subscribe and check out
the new G fuel right now we have 30% off
if you entered the code PewDiePie it's
delicious
don't call yourself a gamer if you don't
have it bye bye
you know what's big peepees do they play
PewDiePie pixel ings of course
pixal ings is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
bazillion players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score it's safe to
say it's the most popular game of all
time PewDiePie pick slings it's awesome
deal with it
[Music]